management / Forest has changed quite a
bit for one hour fire policy is the one
thing we used to think of wildfires is
that they are bad for the forest and
that was part part of that was because
we thought we were going to run out of
timber in the United States we thought
we were gonna have a timber shortage
around 1900 and that wasn't that wasn't
the case we can grow timber were capable
of producing wood for the United States
and fire always seen as a threat to that
and now we see fire as it as an integral
part of ecosystems and in acts within
different ecosystems very very
differently and so now that we're trying
to understand that we can use it as a
tool in order to prevent catastrophic
wildfires in some places or allow them
to occur in some places there's less
fear in it but it's important that if
we're not going to fear it we need to
understand it for decades foresters have
used fire to thin overgrown forest areas
vulnerable to catastrophic wildfire at
the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies students ignite a
prescribed burn to manage the health of
the 7800 acre Gail Myers forest I'm Joe
of a PJ I'm a second year master of
forestry student with Yale University
and that we're gonna be doing a
prescribed burn here today on Yale Myers
forest this is a site we're gonna walk
around it show everybody the boundaries
so we know where the fire needs to be
and where we don't want fire and so fire
occurs where we don't want it we're
gonna put it out that's the idea this is
about an acre the whole sites two acres
but we're going to burn only half of it
today so the purpose of these is for an
ant can speak more on this but it's for
we do ecological research if you look
behind you there's some pipe sticking
out of the ground and that's a research
site and so that site won't be burned
within this fire and so we can compare
areas that aren't burned on the same
site but there is that were burned and
get differences this site we refer to as
the oak savannah and you can see the
very large trees that are widely spaced
Oaks whether this size are resistant
bark is thick enough to be resistant to
the light fires that were setting these
oak Savannah's are very important for
certain wildlife species the large
opening with a few large trees is the
forest structure that we're trying to
develop in this area through the use of
fire we can come in and cut and that was
what was originally done is a lot of
things were cut leaving some nice large
oaks but as you can see there's all
kinds of saplings that come up we could
go in and we could either herbicide them
or we could cut them with with clippers
but because we also have a course on
fire science and policy at the Yale
School of Forestry one way to
incorporate some of the research that
we're doing with classroom work is to
have a prescribed burn here every few
years we burn the site in the past and
if you look over here to where we have
burned there's no small saplings whereas
if you if you look at the site behind us
there's saplings that are almost 20 feet
tall so it's clear that the fire is
controlling the unwanted vegetation
which in this case is black birch
regeneration when the trees are this
small it's very easy to kill them
because all we have to do is keep the
cambial tissues heat them up to 60
degrees centigrade for about a minute
and it just it cooks the cambial tissues
but it will sprout it will continually
sprout so we have to continually do this
a hands-off policy toward forests fails
to acknowledge the historic ecological
role of fire the result persistent
catastrophic wildfires in the West
prescribed burns can play an important
role in reducing forest fuel loads we're
now learning that many of the roles that
fire played were important day cycle
nutrients and places that are very dry
like the inland western US fire renews
the forest now when we have too much
fuel on the ground such as with a
hundred years of excluding fire
the kinds of fires that are burning are
not the kinds that burned historically
and we want to get back to putting fire
in the ecosystem as a process but under
the natural range of variability that
you would have seen it not some of these
catastrophic wildfires that are a result
a direct result of huge fuel build ups
and droughty climates we're a global
school of the environment that
encompasses quite a broad arena we
define forestry much more broadly than
many schools do for more information
about the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies visit environment
yale edu